[Musica]
alzi la mano che arriva sempre in
ritardo agli
appuntamenti quanti siamo E invece che
arriva sempre in anticipo Ah anche qui
un bel
po' bene quello che faremo oggi provare
a smontare queste
etichette forse non saremo più le
persone che arrivano troppo presto o
troppo tardi ma saremo semplicemente
delle persone che vivono nel loro
tempo sin da piccola sembrava che il mio
orologio andasse a un ritmo diverso
rispetto agli altri quando ai compleanni
dei miei compagni e delle mie compagne
di scuola i miei genitori mi facevano
fretta per accompagnarmi io rispondevo
sempre che fretta c'è mica dobbiamo
arrivare per
primi poi è arrivata l'adolescenza e con
essa il mio primo lascia passare verso
l'indipendenza il
motorino tre quarti delle volte io però
in motorino andavo da sola Primo perché
avevo fatto tre incidenti in una
settimana quindi diciamo che era
important non avere nessuno sulla
coscienza secondo perché finalmente
potevo muovermi con i miei
orari il tempo scorreva al ritmo delle
mie scelte e non sembrava mai
sincronizzarsi con quello degli
altri da queste premesse capirete bene
che l'ingresso nel mondo del lavoro è
stato abbastanza
traumatico la mia prima esperienza
all'estero mi porta in catalunia una
Spagna Ma col tempo svizzero la regola
Infatti era spaccare il
minuto così dopo qualche strigliata la M
vita ha cominciato a essere scandita dal
tempo dell'orologio perdendo
inesorabilmente la nota di
improvvisazione
adolescenziale quando sono rientrata
nella mia città l'ambizione mi aveva
definitivamente
corretta uscivo di casa tutti i giorni
alle
8:15 neanche 5 minuti più tardi per
evitare un imbottigliamento nel traffico
che mi avrebbe fatto arrivare tardi in
ufficio e quindi parcheggio caffè
scrivania riunione pausa pranzo e di
nuovo caffè scrivania riunione Ciao a
tutti A domani E ancora palestra cena
casa doccia Buonanotte tutti i
giorni
spesso facevo fatica a ricordare che
tempo avesse fatto durante la giornata
se c'era stato vento se avesse
piovuto dentro le pareti di
quell'ufficio dove non faceva mai né
troppo caldo né troppo
freddo io ero come dentro una bolla il
tempo non scorreva marciava e aveva il
ritmo della voglia di arrivare dove però
non mi era ben chiaro dell'illusione che
una pianificazione serrata della vita mi
desse accesso di diritto al mondo degli
adulti Ma una vocina dentro di me non
smetteva di bisbigliare
fastidiosamente dentro quella tabella di
marcia serrata il mio spirito
creativo si stava
spegnendo davanti a me vedevo una strada
lunga e salita e anche se dall'alto
Credevo che il panorama sarebbe stato
bellissimo non riuscivo a trovare dentro
di me la motivazione per continuare a
salire ero cresciuta al motto di il
tempo e denaro quanti L'hanno sentito
quanti l'hanno ripetuto E invece io quel
tempo non lo potevo trattenere non lo
potevo risparmiare non lo potevo
acquistare davvero Volevo vivere la mia
vita fissando l'orologio e aspettando
che il tempo passasse per essere
felice Cioè davvero volevo che il tempo
l'unico bene impossibile da
trattenere volasse via
velocemente con l'impulsività dei miei
25 anni mi sono convinta sempre di più
che la vita non poteva essere fatta di
prospettive future l'unico tempo in cui
io potevo agire era
adesso bene Ora penserete che arriva la
parte in cui vi racconto di come ho
mollato un lavoro stabile e sicuro e ho
iniziato a vivere una vita libera e
felice
spoiler non è
così perché da quel momento ha iniziato
a farmi visita un'amichetta che
probabilmente conoscono molti di voi
lei
l'ansia ansia di non essere abbastanza
brava ansia di non riuscire a far tutto
per tempo ansia di non arrivare a fine
mese non lavoravo più sempre dentro lo
stesso ufficio ma avevo costruito
intorno a me una gabbia altrettanto
stretta continuava a barattare il mio
tempo e tutte le mie energie con il
denaro
lì ho capito che non era il tipo di
lavoro che facevo a imprigionarmi
Ma come lo vivevo nella scalata verso
posizioni di
prestigio Stavo perdendo me
stessa
finché non ho trovato la
cura che è rappresentata qui ed è il
viaggio
volevo che il viaggio diventasse la mia
routine non l'episodio eccezionale da
attendere con trepidazione E
incredibilmente potevo farlo portando il
pc dietro stipato insieme a vestiti e
aspettative dentro lo zaino il lavoro
smetteva di essere tutta la mia vita e
diventava una parte bella ed
entusiasmante di essa
oggi mentre scrivo mail faccio riunioni
sono suoni stranieri a cullarmi sono
persone sconosciute a ispirarmi
poi chiudo il PC e mi immergo in quel
luogo che fino a qualche tempo prima era
Ignoto lo chiamano nomadismo digitale la
condizione di chi lavora da remoto
scegliendo liberamente anche il luogo in
cui vive senza vincoli di spazio quindi
lavorare viaggiando e viaggiare
lavorando È un modo bellissimo di vivere
il lavoro no pensare di potersi lasciare
ispirare dal mondo che ci
circonda vedete lì ho
capito che il tempo va diversamente A
seconda di dove
sei alcune volte va al trotto altre al
galoppo altre ancora sta quasi fermo e
c'è una cosa molto bella che mi ha
insegnato il viaggio Ed è che come nel
lavoro come nella vita il punto non è il
risultato ma il
processo così come in un viaggio
L'obiettivo non è arrivare alla meta ma
il
percorso così come in una danza il punto
non è arrivare alla fine ma
ballarla Lo so che sembra
strano però quando finalmente ho capito
che il tempo fluiva che è una delle
parole che preferisco in assoluto mi
sono resa conto di come cambiava la
percezione che io avevo del tempo a
seconda del posto in cui
ero vi racconto un po' di storie per
farvi entrare un po' in questa
prospettiva
mentre ero in Tunisia sono stata
invitata a un
matrimonio non conoscevo gli sposi non
avevo assolutamente idea di come si
svolgesse l'evento queste cose capitano
ogni tanto in
viaggio Ovviamente la prima cosa che ho
chiesto è stata quando inizia mi è stato
risposto Quando ci sono
tutti aveva perfettamente senso in un
evento del genere er
normale che il ritmo fosse guidato dalle
relazioni umane piuttosto che dalle
lancette
dell'orologio il Perù ha addirittura
coniato un modo di definire il tempo a s
stante la ora peruviana che non è
segnata dalle lancette dell'orologio E
infatti gli orologi vengono
deliberatamente ignorati io non ne
indosso più uno proprio dal mio viaggio
in Perù E più o meno la stessa cosa
accade in Messico dove se vuoi
ritrovarti con altre persone scoprirai
che non ti verrà dato un orario ci
vediamo al tramonto e incredibilmente
tutti arrivano
puntuali a Cuba invece ho aspettato un
bus invano per più di 3 ore nessuno era
infastidito a nessuno pareva importare
così quando mi sono decisa a chiedere
informazione a un anziano di passaggio
mi ha risposto ridendo a chi Simi nigna
qui è
così e ancora durante il cammino di
Santiago quando ho incontrato un
sacerdote coreano abbiamo condiviso
giusto qualche chilometro insieme però
raccontandoci le nostre vite ho fatto
una domanda all'apparenza banale gli ho
chiesto quanti anni
hai la risposta è stato tutt'altro che
banale mi ha risposto ho 33 anni
coreani dico vabbè sono 33 anni e basta
No perché l'età in Corea viene calcolata
diversamente rispetto
all'Europa io avevo già un anno mi ha
detto quando sono nato perché ero vivo
nella pancia di mia mamma e compio gli
anni il primo gennaio anche se non è
quello il giorno in cui sono nato E
allora se Tutto cambia quando cambiamo
l'attitudine Ma cosa ce le portiamo a
fare modi di vivere e tutte le
distrazioni che abbiamo a casa
nostra ma c'è un'altra cosa che il
viaggio mi ha insegnato e questo
esperimento che mi è stato raccontato È
forse il miglior modo che ho trovato per
condividerla con
voi per deformazione personale
ovviamente Io userò una
valigia
vedete dentro questa
valigia ci sono vestiti
maglioni
scarpe vi sembra
piena siete legittimati a rispondere vi
sembra piena no E infatti non è piena
Posso ancora aggiungere la mia
attrezzatura da
lavoro adesso è piena per
voi posso ancora aggiungere dei
souvenir
Vedete se avessi permesso per prima i
souvenir o l'attrezzatura da lavoro
probabilmente poi non ci sarebbe più
stato spazio per i maglioni
Ecco i
maglioni rappresentano quello che è più
importante nella nostra vita la salute
gli amici l'amore la famiglia tutto ciò
che realmente
conta l'attrezzatura da lavoro
ovviamente è anch'essa importante perché
Rappresenta ciò che fa da contorno alla
nostra vita ciò che ci arricchisce
contribuisce a renderci Fel
i souvenir
invece
rappresentano le piccole cose quelle che
però ci tolgono tempo ed energia lo
scroll apatico sul cellulare i litigi
inutili ciò che facciamo solo per
obbligo
bene Vi chiedo e mi
chiedo di cosa vogliamo riempire la
valigia della nostra
vita il nostro tempo è limitato lo
sappiamo bene se non mettiamo per prime
le esperienze più significative le
emozioni di valore i nostri maglioni poi
non ci sarà più spazio
e questa Polaroid
invece serve a
ricordarci che non importa quanto la sia
piena c'è sempre spazio per fermarci ad
ascoltare concediamoci il tempo di
godere del tempo non è troppo tardi
perché oggi potrebbe essere il primo
giorno del resto della nostra vita
quindi semplicemente il mio invito Il
mio
augurio è che possiate vivere nel vostro
tempo
[Applauso]
Grazie